Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
Reviewer: Krystian Aparta
About three years ago,
I lost my daughter.
She was sexually assaulted and murdered.
She was my only child
and was just 19.
As the shock wore off
and the all-consuming grief took over,
I lost all meaning and purpose in life.
Then my daughter spoke to me.
She asked me to keep living.
If I am not around,
she will have one less heart
to continue to live in.
With that, my partner Susan and I
started our desperate climb
out of this deep hole of trauma and loss.
In the journey back to the land
of the living with grief,
we unexpectedly found
a rather unlikely and very helpful ally:
my work.
At first, I wasn't even sure
if I should go back to work.
I had a lot of self-doubt.
As a senior executive,
I'm responsible for thousands of employees
and billions of dollars.
After all that trauma,
is my mind still sharp
and creative enough for that job?
Can I still relate to people?
Can I get past the resentment
and regret I felt
about all the time I spent working
instead of being with my daughter?
Is it fair to leave Susan home alone,
dealing with her own grief and pain?
At the end,
I made the decision to go back to work,
and I am very glad I did.
We all experience grief
and loss in our lives.
For most of us,
that means, at some point,
getting up and getting back to work
while living with the grief.
On those days,
we will continue to carry
the incredible burden of sadness,
but also a hope that work itself
can restore for us
that much-needed feeling of purpose.
For me, work started out
as just a productive distraction,
but evolved to being truly therapeutic
and meaningful in so many ways.
And my return to work proved to be
a good thing for the company as well.
I know I'm not indispensable,
but retaining my expertise
proved to be very beneficial,
and my return helped all the teams
avoid disruptions and distractions.
When you lose the most
precious thing in your life,
you gain a lot of humility
and a very different perspective
free of egos and agendas,
and I think I'm a better coworker
and a leader because of that.
For all the good
that came from it, though,
my reentry into work was far from easy.
It was very hard.
The biggest challenge
was having to separate my personal
and professional lives completely.
You know --
OK to cry early in the morning,
but slap a smile on the face
promptly at eight o'clock
and act as if everything
is the same as before
until the workday is over.
Living in two completely different
worlds at the same time,
and all the hiding and pretending
that went with it,
it was --
it was exhausting,
and made me feel very alone.
Over time, I worked
through those struggles
and I gained the confidence
and the acceptance to bring
my whole self to work.
And as a direct result of that,
I found joy again in it.
During that hard journey back to work,
I learned the power of having
a culture of empathy in the workplace.
Not sympathy,
not compassion,
but empathy.
I came to believe
that a workplace where empathy
is a core part of the culture,
that is a joyful and productive workplace,
and that workplace inspires
a great deal of loyalty.
I believe there are three things
a company can do
to create and nurture a culture
of empathy in the workplace in general
and support a grieving employee
like myself in particular.
One is to have policies
that let an employee
deal with their loss in peace,
without worrying
about administrative logistics.
Second, provide return-to-work
therapy to the employee
as an integral part
of the health benefits package.
And third,
provide training for all employees
on how to support each other --
empathy training, as I call it.
In the first category of policies
to help deal with the loss,
the most important policy
is regarding time off.
It's true that there is
no expiration date to grieve
and time cannot undo a loss,
but time away from work helped me
figure out how daily life
can coexist with grief.
We don't want a grieving employee
to have to cobble together vacation days
and sick days
and unpaid leave and whatever else.
A formal time-off policy
that also allows the employee
to come back to the same role they had
before their time off --
that policy will make a real difference.
Personally, I was so grateful
to come back to my old role.
The familiar work, familiar people,
provided a lot of comfort.
The second category of help
companies can provide to employees
is return-to-work therapy.
Therapy helped me muster
the courage needed
to bring my whole self to work
and merge the two parallel worlds
I was straddling into one,
and just have one life.
A couple of years ago,
I spent a weekend scattering
my daughter's ashes in the Pacific.
It was a --
it was a horrific time.
When I returned to work from that
that following Monday,
one of the first meetings was to arbitrate
a very passionate debate
on office wallpaper.
I needed therapy to figure out
how to be considerate
of others' normal lives
when my own life is so very different.
Therapy helped me give myself
permission to be vulnerable.
Even if vulnerability is not often seen
as a strength in the corporate world,
when seemingly unrelated
and just trivial things
triggered deep feelings of sadness
right smack in the middle of the workday,
therapy helped me deal with them.
And when painful anniversaries
and events tried to hijack the day,
like when I got a call from Texas Rangers
regarding an arrest in my child's death,
I was at work.
Therapy helped me stay productive
while still remaining true
to the unique realities
and the painful realities of my life.
During the course
of the return-to-work therapy,
I had realized something.
I had realized that many
of those learnings,
they would have been very helpful
for me at work all along,
independent of my loss.
And that realization
brings me to the final category
of things companies can do.
Provide empathy training to the employees.
Look, I know it sounds odd,
but empathy can be a learned behavior.
For some, showing empathy comes naturally.
A colleague came to see me;
I had this electronic
photo frame on my desk,
rotating through pictures of my daughter.
As she was leaving, she simply said,
"Tilak, when you're ready,
I would love for you to tell me
the story behind each of those pictures."
She didn't ignore my sadness;
she didn't dwell on it.
She simply gave me
permission to be myself
and made a human connection.
This was her version of empathy,
of which I'm sure there are many.
But not everybody
is a natural with empathy,
and traditional work cultures
don't always emphasize empathy.
One person said to me,
"I can't believe you made it back to work.
I don't think I could have done it."
Boy, did that make me feel awful.
Is my love for my child not strong?
Another person decided
to be my spokesperson,
guiding other folks on how
and when to interact with me,
all without my knowledge or consent.
A few folks just maintained
absolute stoic and deafening silence,
which in some ways trivialized my loss.
Some spent a ton of water-cooler time
speculating if I would be
any good at all at work,
coming back from such a devastating loss.
Time, frankly, would have
been better spent
in figuring out how to help me instead.
And then there was that moment
where I had to console someone,
very distraught,
who said, "I understand your loss.
My dog died last year."
Empathy training can help avoid
that inherent awkwardness
in dealing with loss.
It can give people the confidence
to bring their whole self to work,
and the people around them,
the awareness to accept
them for who they are.
And together,
we'll all be better for it.
Empathy training can help
people acknowledge
that a coworker is a very different person
after a life-changing loss,
and ask that simple and direct question:
what would you like me
to do differently to help you?
There will come a day
when I finally see my daughter,
my little girl,
again.
And as she always did,
she's going to make fun of me
for working so much.
But she knew.
She knew that she was the top priority --
number one priority.
And she will be thankful that work
helped Dad live a purposeful life
after she was gone.
It is such an incredible relief
that the loss I experienced
is not as common.
A child dying ahead of the parent
is just absolutely horrific --
the most nightmarish
and unnatural thing to happen.
But loss in itself is not uncommon.
When done right,
returning to work can help us
survive loss and grief.
And companies can help do it right,
by fostering a culture
of empathy in the workplace.
It's not a burden
or a lot of effort or expense.
And creating such a workplace,
where empathy is core to the culture --
it will be one of the best
investments a company can make.
Thank you.